hey guys it's me in this video we're
going to talk about how to fix a broken
metabolism this is the most important
thing you need to know so if you're
doing anything right now that's
distracting you put it away get a piece
of paper take notes okay the first thing
I need to do is give you a little
foundation so you understand what I'm
gonna talk about next
okay so I'm gonna kind of build on this
so so as we go just take notes number
one there's some the facts about the
metabolism is that when you go on a diet
you will slow your metabolism so dieting
slows your metabolism if you've dyed it
for many many years
and then your metabolism is very very
slow if you've never dyed it then your
metabolism is probably a lot faster okay
so dieting also increases hunger and
cravings if you never look at the show
The Biggest Loser they always make it
look so you know like dramatic like how
can they lose all that weight but what
happens when these guys start losing
they start slowing down and slowing down
where it's really really tough until
they have to exercise so hard to get off
that last bit of weight it's crazy and
then they don't show they have to sign a
waiver
many of these people gain the weight
right back okay and I'll tell you why in
a second so also age slows your
metabolism surprised you're probably
already finding it out so exercise will
increase hunger and cravings too with
some people but mainly hunger because
you're you're burning stuff up you're
going to want more and the last thing is
it's very unnatural to lose weight very
unnatural losing weight is anti survival
because fat is a survival mechanism so
when you try to lose it it goes against
a survival so really we need to dive in
like the understanding of what that is
so we can undo it but we're talking
really about your set point and the set
point is the point at which your body
very uh likes to be weight wise it's
just settles into the certain point it
doesn't like to go below that it might
not even go higher than that but it
likes to settle down at a certain point
so my goal is to help
in this video show you how to lower that
setpoint so for example let's say your
setpoint is 182 and you want to get to
142 so we need to drop the set point and
that's really the metabolism point where
your body kind of settles into it likes
to the body just likes to be the same it
doesn't like to go down too much because
that's starvation right so what we want
to do is give you the next part of this
a foundation of how how we're going to
fix the setpoint but first we have to
talk about what destroys the setpoint
beyond just dieting okay so let me show
you that okay so here's what you need to
know number one you have this thing
called the pancreas it's located
underneath your left ribcage and the
pancreas has about a million islands of
cells okay and there's this little
little tiny it looks like little ions
islands in a bunch of tissue and they
call it islands of Langerhans after the
guys name who discovered it but there's
different cells and they're called alpha
beta Delta cells the beta cells are the
ones that were going to talk about first
and 60% of those cells are made of cells
okay and the other 40% are other cells
know what is beta cells the beta cells
make insulin okay so that's what they do
so insulin is most known for regulating
sugar right in carbohydrates so what
insulin does is it lowers the sugar in
the blood okay so that's what I'm going
to kind of build on this but you need to
understand that so insulin lowers the
sugar and but the other thing is that
insulin also has other functions that a
lot of people don't realize number one
it affects fat metabolism it affects
protein metabolism okay so it makes it
converts sugar into cholesterol it
converts sugar into triglycerides those
are blood fats it basically increases
the tension on the arteries increasing
blood pressure it retains sodium
okay it drives protein or amino acids
into the cells and so there's a and
we'll get more into that in a bit but I
wanted just to have you understand that
protein insulin is a lot more to do just
just in carbohydrate metabolism but for
your viewpoint what you need to know
right now is that it's the thing that
makes you makes fat it's the primary
regulator that makes you fat and it
actually blocks any chance of burning
fat in the presence of a little bit of
insulin you're not going to burn fat
period okay and this is out of guidance
physiology and this is a known fact so
it'll make you fat and blocks the
release of that okay so we have insulin
that is triggered by a high carbohydrate
meal you probably know that you need
some bread you increase sugar and what
happens your body will store that into a
stored sugar called glycogen so glycogen
is a series of glucose molecules stuck
together okay
it needs potassium to be stored so we
got stored sugar and then anything
excess it turns into fat okay so we have
a combination of stored sugar and fat
okay that's what insulin does and so
what happens though with a lot of people
is they start getting a fatty liver so
it's really the insulin that makes the
fatty liver especially if the person is
not consuming alcohol all right and then
insulin if gone on too far will destroy
proteins yeah muscle wasting all the
programming think about what part of
your body's protein
you got intracellular proteins you have
like so many different proteins your
body is gonna waste those and it's going
to convert those into sugar and it's
going to leave carbon skeletons so it's
just basically going to leave the waste
and it's going to convert everything
else to sugar and basically that's what
destroys the diabetic is that they get
clogged arteries a stroke they have
their kidneys fail
and then they had a protein destruction
that's why they usually have protein
coming out of the kidneys and they
destroy that and say you have everything
that kind of spills off into the rest of
the tissue so it's a very ugly
destructive disorder and then what
happens normally there's supposed to
happen is before a meal you should have
a blood sugar between let's say 75 and
90 like it's say 80 and 90 okay but
normal also it can go up to 100 so let's
say between 80 and a hundred that's
normal before you eat okay what happens
though when you eat the blood sugar
should normally spike up to like 120 it
can even go up up to like 140 after a
meal okay but the closer you get to 140
the more you're becoming a problem so if
it's above 140 then you become more
diabetic because of diabetes you have
this spike in sugar because the insulin
is not there to keep it in check so it's
out of control
so what happens normally is you eat it
comes spikes to 120 and then it comes
back down to normal after 2 to 3 hours
that's normal because the insulin
controls that blood sugar but in a
diabetic situation it raises too high
out of control you get tired brain fog
and then it takes a long time to come
back and reset okay so so now let's go
on to the next part high insulin over
time or plus time equals insulin
resistance now a good analogy would be
let's say you live in or near the train
track and there's a train that goes over
your house and you live like there's
like a metro or something and at first
you can't sleep because it's so noisy
but over time you you become
desensitized you don't hear it anymore
because you get used to it so same thing
being exposed to an antibiotic you
become antibiotic resistant okay so when
you have too much of a hormone
especially insulin the receptor that's
supposed to receive that hormone gets
altered it compensates it downgrades so
it doesn't absorb it so basically your
body is trying to reject insulin because
it's too high okay so what causes this
and resist
this is too much insulin okay so you
have a situation where you have too much
insulin but you also have not enough
insulin in certain places of your body
like in the self and in the blood but we
have too much insulin other places so
you can have symptoms of both hyper and
hypoglycemia interesting so let's go
through the symptoms fatty liver okay if
you have a fatty liver you have insulin
resistance if you have insulin
resistance you have found a liver
because one thing will also cause
another because some of the fat in liver
actually releases certain inflammatory
responses that make you insulin
resistance so it's really a nasty
double-edged sword brain fog okay high
fasting insulin so even when you're not
eating sugar the insulin is still high
in certain places of your body
remember insulin blocks fat burning okay
belly fat blow team digestive issues
sleep sleepy after meal light so you eat
lunch and you have to take a nap that's
classic
insulin resistance high blood blood
pressure why because insulin causes
tension within the arteries cravings and
hunger well wait a second that's a low
insulin situation but it's an insulin
resistance symptom but it's really
certain parts of your body have a low
insulin because the cell won't let it
kind of connect so you're basically
craving and hungry all the time dark
pigment in your folds up in different
folds of your body like you're growing
your armpits your neck you have a little
a darker pigmentation that can happen in
advanced stages and hunger between meals
so you can't go a long period of time
without getting hungry or having a blood
sugar issue that's insulin resistance so
in sun resistance is the single biggest
problem for that controls your setpoint
it destroys your setpoint okay
why because insulin is is the hormone
that tells your body whether to burn fat
or not okay it's going to it's going to
become more clear as we
go through the next part - so insulin
increases fat prevents the burning of
fat and controls and destroys your
setpoint other net is perfectly fine let
me show you the next part okay so now
the big question is what causes insulin
resistance okay high insulin but what
causes insulin to spike right you
already know it's sugar but there's some
other things that will increase insulin
as well and that would be protein some
types of protein more than others okay
and what I'm talking about is I'm
talking about the protein doesn't
trigger glucose so you've probably heard
of the glycemic index right well that's
the level of the foods that trigger the
sugars but have you ever heard of the
insulin index completely different okay
I'm going to talk about the next section
but the point is there are other factors
that will increase insulin that don't
increase glucose it's this is this
explains why you probably are eating
healthy no sugars and you're still not
at losing weight now before you get
freaked out and say hey I have to not
have to give up protein hear me out okay
because there's some other solutions but
the point is that especially for eating
a large amount of proteins but protein
does trigger insulin to some degree if
we look at the different types of
proteins well let me just say that - the
next one
but gastrointestinal hormones what does
that mean it means that there are
hormones in your your GI tract that also
increase in fund so really every time
you eat you increase insulin okay so
there's a couple of foods that don't
increase insulin I'll I'll get into that
next section but the point I'm trying to
make is that there's other things that
are messing you up other than just the
sugar estrogen increases insulin as well
yeah that explains why women when they
get pregnant they go through the
menstrual cycle they get fatter okay
especially if the estrogen is too high
so so we're going to talk about the
insulin index in the next section
alright now check this out
this is the insulin index okay very
different than the glycemic index for
the most part but look at butter it's 2%
it's very very low does barely triggers
influent at all just slightly okay olive
oil 3% coconut oil 3% so really all the
fats are there's no stimulation and this
is why you can get away with eating the
fat more than going low-fat because
watch what happens as we go up the scale
we have low fat yogurt 76% so when you
go low fat cheese we get rid of the
buffer for the insulin and the protein
is higher and you get more insulin so
all these low fat things at the store
are creating insulin problems because
they're not using the fat as a buffer
for insulin and that's why even ice
cream recipe that I have is that the
heavy cream look at heavy cream is 4%
okay that's low it doesn't stimulate
insulin so it's not gonna it's not going
to destroy the setpoint it's not going
to create a problem now you can eat too
much of it but the point is that it's
not going to be the importance of
getting rid of it is very very minimal
okay so it's it's much more important to
avoid the higher insulin things but
check this out egg yolk 15% that's
pretty low but look at the egg the whole
egg and I'm sorry leg whites is 55% how
many people do you know that just do egg
whites thinking they're doing themselves
some good and they're not doing the egg
yolk the egg yolk is much better for
weight loss if we combine the egg yolk
with the egg whites we get the whole egg
it brings it down to 21% so by adding
fat with a meal you're actually helping
the situation now it is true when you go
through ketosis you can you could be
burning your own your dietary fat and
not your own fat but don't be afraid to
consume whole things don't go lean at
all okay
don't be afraid to use some butter don't
be afraid to use some of these products
so look at this we got peak
it's very very low bacon 9% see in your
mind you're probably like why needs some
lean bacon no you don't you want the
fattier bacon because the leaner the
protein the more spikes insulin peanut
butter 11% cheese 15% turkey 23% berries
47 look at beef 51% so these people that
do the Atkins diet let's say they do it
the first time it works the second time
it doesn't really work as well the third
time it doesn't work at all why because
dieting slows and metabolism it destroys
the setpoint and they're actually
increasing their insulin not as bad as a
sugar person but that's really what
happens look at Apple 75% low-fat yogurt
76 percent of banana 84 percent whole
wheat bread 96 baked beans a hundred
percent potatoes 121 percent I'm going
to give you a download you can download
this page in the download section so you
have a whole list of this and I will
also share in the extra section some
food plans to show you what food you
should be eating just to take it one one
step further ok now so I'm just bringing
your awareness up that there are foods
that are messing you up they're not
necessarily sugars okay and I want to
show you next this one little point here
which is very very very important and
and I know I kind of spent a lot of time
getting to this point but this is the
most important point of this whole
presentation okay so if high levels of
insulin over a period of time causes and
resistance then what happens is we have
breakfast lunch and dinner right so
here's the problem when we eat even the
hormones in our digestive tract spike
insulin boom okay so we know we're gonna
get rid of this sugar and all that and
that's great but if you snack in between
the meals if you're
aking even with healthy things okay
you're spiking the insulin so we never
have a chance to correct insulin
resistance so you must shoot for three
meals a day or two not to lower calories
because we're going to increase some fat
but simply to correct the insulin
resistance now how do you know if you
have inserted resistance well all those
symptoms if you have belly fat if you
you have you're going to have a fatty
liver if you have a fatty liver you're
going to have insulin resistance if you
have insulin resistance you're going to
have a fatty liver a fatty liver you're
going to have visceral fat around here
so it's all kind of connected so the
point is that you want to shoot for only
doing three meals a day okay that's
number one but here's the thing some
people when they get up in the morning
are not hungry so don't eat even though
the breakfast is the most important your
breakfast might be delayed until lunch
if you're not hungry in that morning
don't consume any food only eat when
you're hungry this this is a lie to
state that you need six meals a day it's
just going to screw things up so we
don't eat until we're hungry and then we
eat okay now if you want a little snack
let's say circuit free chocolate or
whatever you can eat that right at the
end of the meal but not in the middle of
the meals not between meals if you are
so hungry and ravenously craving between
meals then we have to increase a little
bit more food during the meal itself
specifically fat low glycemic fat okay
and what that means is you have insulin
resistance that's why you have almost
like a blood sugar issue there and then
the same thing at night don't consume
past your dinner okay now some of my
clients are doing they're basically
they're not hungry in the morning they
eat a big lunch and they need a dinner
and they're done two meals and that's
incredible because you're doing an
intermittent fasting for the next period
of time so you're gonna you're gonna
heal the insulin resistance you're going
to lower your setpoint me I have to hit
you to breakfast and then a lunch and I
barely will have a dinner I'm
have a small little kale shake and I'm
done so it's like two and a half meals a
day so you can do that as well
but the key is don't snack at night okay
you can drink tea and things like that
all right
so and then the last section I'm going
to give you a series of additional
things that you can do to improve
insulin resistance
okay so intermittent fasting is a very
important thing to implement but you
don't necessarily have to go the whole
day without eating you can start with
three meals and then go down to two if
you want to alternate and do every other
day you know skip a meal that's totally
fine to kiyose as you do this you're
gonna control your sugar it's better
between meals and you won't have to eat
as much because you're thinking about it
when you're fasting you're living off
your own fat if you have reserve to burn
then might as well burn that up when you
hit your goal you don't necessarily have
to do fast anymore it's not starving
your body it's basically getting your
body just more efficiently just switch
over to fat-burning and not burn your
sugar because if you actually can't make
it to the next meal that means that
you're just burning sugar so we have to
improve this so there's several things
we can do to lower insulin okay number
one apple cider vinegar helps blood
Sugar's tremendously so you can consume
that with a meal if you don't like it
you can consume it as a pill put in but
if you're gonna do it in water a
teaspoon per glass okay fermented foods
are much better for insulin than
anything else so fermented cabbage
sauerkraut that's all really good
because it has a vinegar in it as well
high potassium food that would be all
the vegetables now here's the problem
when we do this when we lower insulin
you're going to be living off your fat
and you're gonna have a lot more fat
being burned which means that your liver
has to process a lot more fat burning if
you do this without eating enough
vegetables you're gonna end up with a
fatty or liver so there is no choice you
have to consume larger amounts of greens
you can blend them you can drink them
but you need to consume that to keep the
fat flesh from the liver that's the only
way you're going to get rid of the fatty
liver okay so then we got high potassium
foods that's vegetables high vitamin b1
is also will decrease the need for
insulin that would be a nutritional
yeast okay make sure you don't buy the
synthetic version though fiber it's also
in my adrenal de formula to have b1
that's a natural one fiber like if
you're going to do a choice between a
kale shake with the fiber like a blended
versus a juice it's better to do the
fiber because the fiber buffers the
insulin okay so we want fiber rich foods
celery is great fat consume more pure
fats why it's not that we're telling you
that fats going to necessarily cause you
to lose a lot of weight but it's very
sustaining between the meals and it has
no effect on insulin it's gonna help
correct it so what we're trying to do is
we're trying to get you to eat enough
fat so you can go longer without having
to eat the reason why we're going longer
is so we can reverse the flow and not
have sustained persistent insulin but
have like a low instance situation
because if you have diabetes and you and
you constantly have high sugar well if
you don't eat you're not gonna have high
sugar so guess what this is really good
for a diabetic and this is how you
reverse diabetes because what is insulin
resistance it's a type 2 diabetes but
you can have a version of it doesn't
come like this you can have a small
version of it that's not it's like a
pre-diabetes situation okay so lowering
cortisol that's with the stress reducing
the stress doing my adrenal techniques
all that removing body stress is
important because cortisol releases
glucose which increases insulin and
reducing estrogen if you have too much
of it so if your period is heavy we can
do the technique on the ovaries if
you're taking estrogen not a great idea
because it's going to cause you to gain
weight sleeping more is going to lower
insulin exercising is going to lower
insulin we talked about vegetables okay
so I gave you a lot of things that you
can do go ahead and start with the inner
minute fasting or leave 3 meals and no
snacks and then try to go to overtime
okay and watch what happens
your setpoint is going to go down this
is how you fix it bro
can metabolism